[Music]
we're officially entering the completely
insane phase of the 2016 election I know
it feels like we've been here for about
a year now but if you think the
political theater has been crazy so far
trust me you ain't seen nothing yet it
seems that everyone you know is starting
to crack right I mean you could just
open up Twitter or Facebook and every
second of the day it seems like someone
is writing something crazy nobody has a
clue as to what's going on anymore and
you don't have to take my word for that
just turn on CNN or fox or MSNBC and
listen to the pundits who got everything
wrong for the last six months
explain how the next six months are
gonna go these are the experts in what I
have no idea
last week I discussed what I consider to
be the biggest risk of a trump
presidency we have a salesman doing a
hell of a sales job but we really don't
know what kind of product we're gonna
end up with in the end as some of you
pointed out the notion of not knowing
how someone will act once in office is
actually no different than with most
politicians they pretty much all will
say anything to get elected and then do
whatever they can to stay in power
ironically this endless loop of promises
made and broken by politicians who just
want to stay in office is exactly what
has led to the rise of Donald Trump
people are sick of the status quo and
are willing to turn to a reality TV host
as their Savior some of you pointed out
if my question of whether Trump would
even believe in our three branches of
government was legit many presidents
have done plenty via executive action
effectively circumvent in Congress and
usually like in the case of Barack Obama
they're against using executive actions
until they're in office themselves of
course presidents shouldn't get all the
blame for executive actions it's not as
if this Congress has been eager to get
anything done with the president
regardless of who's to blame though the
average person sees usurping of power
and Washington gridlock in their minds
is a regular politician gonna get our
country out of that pattern no but an
over-the-top businessman might while we
can parse out why Trump has risen the
fact is he is here and all of us have to
acknowledge there is a political
in brewing on the horizon it may not be
the one you like but trying to silence
trump supporters by blocking roads to
rallies or by labeling all his
supporters racist isn't gonna stop his
rise actually it's just gonna make his
support that much stronger this is why I
always talk about the Battle of ideas on
this show and it's not only why I talk
about them it's why I invite guests from
all over the political map to share in
their views and guess what yeah
sometimes they say things that I don't
agree with but I don't shout them down
the only way we can ever make progress
is by hearing others this should be the
number one principle of being a
progressive but these days it's not even
on their top 10 list if you hate Trump
if you think his comments about Muslims
are horrible if you think his border
wall is terrible and you think his
general disposition is disgusting then
use your speech to promote a candidate
with better ideas if you like Bernie
then help Bernie get the vote out if you
like Hillary then tell your friends why
if you like Ted Cruz well then you're
the only one but good for you the point
is we've never needed a battle of ideas
more in this country than we do right
now and we shouldn't be afraid to have
it but here's a scary part a battle of
ideas means actually hearing people out
so yes you can use your free speech to
protest Trump or anyone else that's as
American as it gets but big goddamn deal
if you're offended suck it up and move
on like you should have learned in
fourth grade do you think the people who
block the road to the Trump rally
changed the mind of one person that they
stopped from getting there no they
actually did the complete opposite
because they didn't have a battle of
ideas they had a battle of Mad Max fury
road on a highway in Arizona my guest
this week is the infamous notorious and
always outspoken Milo innopolis Milo is
a provocateur whose rise to stardom in
some ways mirrors Trump's which might
explain his support for the Donald Milo
is using all the tools of the internet
to spread his message against the
authoritarians not only does he always
get a reaction but he's paid the price
losing his blue twitter verification
check and being protested at several
universities on his current college tour
he's sort of a micro Trump
and that he uses the media to a fuel his
ascent to stardom while I have many
differences of opinion with Milo we find
ourselves as allies in the war on free
speech and against ideologies that would
silence us both there is way more that
unites us as a people and as a country
than the media will ever tell us decency
respect and humanity just aren't very
clickable fry its protests and violence
will always be the lead story thus
fueling the fire of intolerance that's
why I said you ain't seen nothing yet we
could end up with a contested convention
for the Republicans a super delegate
revolt by the Democrats a sudden third
party candidate or who knows what else
the important thing is that we learn to
respect one another while this insane
process unfolds around us if our leaders
aren't going to be great then it's time
for us to do some leading ourselves
you